we're asked to construct a 10 degree
angle so they give us we have this
little angle tool here that we can use
to construct
to construct an angle
so just like that and then we gave us a
give us a protractor to actually measure
the angle so let's
set it up
let's put the protractor here let's put
the vertex of the angle at the center of
the protractor or another way of the
center of the protractor the center of
the vertex looks like the protractor is
a little bit easier to manipulate so
let's do that there
now let's put one of the rays let's put
one of the rays here at 0 degrees and
now i'm going to put the other ray at 10
degrees
and it looks like i am done i have
constructed a 10 degree angle and you
want to be careful here when you use
this tool because the angle in question
let me remove the protractor see what
i'm talking about that this right over
here is the angle that we're talking
about if i had switched these two rays
the way the tool is set up it might have
viewed interpreted the angle as this
outer angle right over here so be
careful to to look at which angle we're
actually measuring but look this looks
like i did the 10 degree angle so let me
check my answer and just to be clear
what i'm talking about if you did the 10
degree angle like this
like this that it probably or definitely
would have marked it wrong even though
the interior angle right over here or
this
this angle right over here might be 10
degrees the way the tool is set up you
see from this circle that it thinks that
you're looking at this outer angle so
it's important to make sure at least for
this the sake of this exercise to that
this that the system the the computer
program knows which angle you're going
to talk about let's do one more of these
155 degree angle this one's interesting
because this is an obtuse angle so once
again
let us put the protractor at the
at the vertex of the angle
so
just like that
and now
that seems pretty good now let's take
one ray and put it at zero degrees
and then let's take the other one and
put it at 155 so once again 10 20 30 40
50 60 70 80 90. that gets us to a right
angle then we start getting into obtuse
angles 100 110 120 130 140
150 and i'm just to make sure that blue
arc is measuring this angle right over
here not the outer one and let me move
the protractor out of the way so we can
get a good look at it and
we got it wrong
so let's see what we oh
155 degree angle not 150 degree angle
let me fix that
155 degree angle
now we got it right